- You're known around these parts,
like everybody heard you were coming here,
and all the ladies, they call you a zaddy.
Do you know what a zaddy is?
(audience oohing)
- Not exactly.
- Well, I actually don't either.
Like I didn't know what
a zaddy was either.
So, I had to get some
of my staff to tell us.
So, Kayla, where you at?
- Over here.
- [Kelly] Kayla's over there.
- I see her.
- Kayla, what makes Jeff a zaddy?
What's a zaddy?
- Well, for whatever reason, Kelly,
kids today feel like being a
dad is lame for some reason.
They think dad jokes are lame.
Dad jeans are lame.
But the fact of the matter is,
there's nothin' lame about being a dad.
And a zad is a man who might
be a little bit more seasoned,
but still has that youthful
zest, youthful zeal.
That's what the Z's coming from.
And Jeff is a prime example of this.
I mean, check out this 'fit.
Y'all have seen his Instagram.
Zaddy all day long.
(audience cheering)
- A zaddy.
- I didn't know.
- So, it's kinda like a MILF,
is that what that is?
For like women?
Or is that not daytime?
You probably can't say that.
You can't say that on daytime, Jeff.
That's just crude.
- Yeah.
I apologize.
- [Kelly] That's crude.
- I'm so sorry.
- I mean, how did you come here
and just say those references?
- I don't know how I can
make it up to you, I'm sorry.
- No, (laughing) what do you
think about being a zaddy?
- I don't know.
(audience laughing)
I like being a daddy.
- He's like I'm still trying
to understand the definition.
That's me, too (laughing).
- I think I get it.
I think it's complimentary.
Thank you.
- It is very complimentary.
- Thank you very much.
But I like being a daddy.
That opened up a whole new world.
- It is such a cool world, yeah.
- Oh my gosh.
- I thought I loved my life
and then I had kids.
Being pregnant with them was horrible,
but afterwards great, yeah.
- Really, I wanna hear about all of that,
but I saw, I've been watching the show,
I saw your kids on the
show when they came out.
Ran to you and hugged you.
I started to get weepy just seeing it.
They're so cute.
- My daughter is more
- Could they be cuter?
- Yeah, my daughter is definitely,
I'm gonna have to like,
I'm gonna have to Kendrick
Lamar humble that one down.
Yeah, she's so, I love it, she's bold,
but she's never met a stranger
and definitely loves attention.
- Really?
- I don't know where
she gets it from, Jeff.